just a forewarning Oh this chapter is
the second lecture on the chapter on the
new Power Balance last time I talked
about technological side of things this
time I'm going to talk about other
things
but I'm not quite sure what they will be
yet because I haven't talked about them
yet one of the concerns that I have
perhaps an overriding concern is this
question of whether the 19th century is
different is it a singular century or
have things occurred before with in
parallel time frames with similar
degrees of change taking place with the
change exhibiting somewhat parallel
degrees of complexity comparison I want
to suggest would be between the period
1700 and 1900 in Europe and Europe
European colonial eyes or influenced
areas and the period 100 to 300 in the
Roman Empire
these are periods and I would say of of
comparable degrees of change other words
you go from having a unified Empire
under a family of Augustus to having a
Christian Empire under con steam that
has now been that is has by fear 300
been divided into an Eastern and a
western empire and is now heavily
populated particularly in its frontier
areas by a new ethnic group our new
ethnic groups I should say whether they
are Berbers in North Africa or
Germans along the Rhine along the Danube
it's a huge political change all right
accompanying that you have an
extraordinary period of syncretism and
of the spread of new ideas often vary
dramatically competing ideas so that
when you look at the early history of
Christianity you do not see a single
unidirectional process but rather you
see a a series of strongly competing
views that spread among different people
and ultimately are incompatible some of
those views get categorized as heresies
for example most of the Germans in
Europe followed the of the views of a
bishop named arias and therefore
recalled the Aryans this has nothing to
do with the word Aryan used by the Nazis
or to talk about the early in the
Europeans they simply followers of a
bishop named Darius his view of
Christianity was that Jesus Christ was
not God he was not part of a Trinity he
was there were various versions of this
some of them were adoptionism whereby
Jesus was adopted by God or other things
in which Jesus takes on a certain divine
quality but is certainly not a
counterpart to the Creator God who
created the universe this became the
standard view for many German peoples
for several centuries even after it was
declared a a an abominable heresy in the
Council of Nicaea in 325
or in the ICEA outside of Constantinople
so there were there reviews like this
that were classified as heresies but
there are many other views that were
outside the Christian purview Isis
worship or Osiris worship or manna ki
ism these were all competing views now
most of them fall into the area of
religion but not entirely neoplatonism
which was extremely popular in this
period had to do with a kind of
elevation of Plato's ideas of of
absolutes to a to a level that was
compatible to some degree with the
notion of divinity so that you had the
idea of a creation of the universe or a
structure of the universe in implying a
creative intelligence where you went
from a from a prime mover a first
principal down through the several
levels of spheres for the planets and
for the moon and the Sun finally down to
the to the earthly sphere also known as
a sub lunar sphere which is the spirit
we inhabit and within that sphere you
had the four elements of earth air fire
and water whereas the celestial spheres
were usually thought it was being pure
fire that these were views you can get
to without any without any divine
revelation they can come straight out of
contemplation of they completely let us
say human writings of Plato and and his
followers like Titus and porphyry and so
forth so it isn't strictly a matter of
of religions my stress that because
the the comparable phenomenon you have
in the 19th century consists of a whole
series of isms Marxism socialism
utopianism and a wide variety of
nationalisms and they compete and some
of them are profoundly antithetical to
others in other words for much of the
history of Marxism devoted as it was to
the idea of that there should be
international solidarity among the
working class among the proletariat the
idea that you would have nationalism
that would stress you know primary
affection for the state within the
boundaries of that state or also
encompassing the imperialist ambitions
that state these are incompatible you
could it be a Marxist and they a
nationalist at least with certain kinds
because one was international and the
other was national or by the end of the
century the contradiction between you
know Marxist inspired socialism and
Zionism Zionism said that there is
something here that is specific to a
people to find us being Jews whether one
is to find that as a religious group or
as an ethnic group whether it's a
nationalism or whether it is a religious
movement different brands of Zionism
will see it in different ways but it
would be seen as incompatible with with
Marxism in its international form which
it was not compatible with the idea that
you'd have one
one group singled out and yet you had
many many Zionists who are socialists
who said I know I can be a socialist but
a communist a Marxist Leninist believing
in a world revolution that's
incompatible with with my Zionism
so as in that in those formative years
of the Roman Empire or Roman Empire
beginning its decline you'll have an
enormous competition in ideas and the
competition is taking place within a
similar timeframe now it's true that you
have print media and higher fast
transportation and so forth them in the
modern period but the the rate at which
people were able to communicate these
new ideas around the Mediterranean in
the Roman Empire is really quite
surprising how much people knew from one
part of the Mediterranean or the Roman
world to another now the reason I think
that this parallel is is never drawn
I've never read anything that drew this
particular parallel is that we are
encouraged to look at political
philosophies differently from religions
and we are encouraged to think that that
there is no basis for comparison of a
political philosophy or a social or an
economic philosophy with with the
religion and I think that that's I think
that's wrong the reason I think it's
wrong is one that I've talked about
before in this class and that is that
the crucial element in in any spread of
something new is the dynamic of the
spread rather than in the substance of
what it is that is new and you've seen
me before draw a graph on the board that
looks like this where you have a
logistic curve in which the the process
of adoption of something follows this
standard curve this curve been
replicated hundreds and thousands of
times in various areas where you start
with a very small number of adopters
they influence each of them a certain a
certain number of potential adopters
some fraction of whom adopt the new
thing and then each of those new
adopters contacts another group of
potential adopters so that you have a
chain reaction in which the the curve is
Arella
is irrelevant with respect to the
content of the adoption it is a curve
that shows the spread of information the
rate at which the information spreads
will determine the slope of the curve
other words it can look like this using
as a time scale or it can look like this
so I can look like that
that has to do with with the particular
phenomenon that you're that you're
looking at but basically what you're
looking at is a exponential growth of
expansion of information that has an
inflection point that then reverses it
so that it you know it slows at the same
rate that it sped up to begin with
because the number of potential adopters
that each individual encounters becomes
smaller simply because so many people
have already adopted the thing now this
curve has been used as I said hundreds
and thousands of times for describing
certain things particularly epidemic
diseases and adoption of institution or
technological innovations it's been used
to not only to to describe the rate of
and pattern of adoption but it has been
used also to predict an adoption curve
so that it also is used very much in
advertising to to model the the adoption
curve that you hope to have and when you
look at it from that point of view or
from any point of view actually you can
divide the curve into certain categories
that are symmetrical categories let's
say this is this curve is the integral
the bell-shaped standard distribution
curve so here is your average here you
have one standard deviation from the
mean here you have two standard
deviations from the mean here you have
three and so forth and so on in other
words the the the categories of people
who are transmitting information can be
defined in statistical terms and then
for people who study this carefully they
will proceed to ascribe social qualities
to the people who are in each category
so we'll say okay let's assume that you
know that's your Model T Ford your you
know your mean adopter know when
everybody is in this time period from
one standard deviation above and once a
deviation below the mean this is where
you're getting your mass adoption of
automobiles but who is adopting
automobiles here who is the first person
to adopt it and then the people who
study this will say well this is a
different personality type or it's a
different social category maybe it's a
difference in wealth maybe it's a
different instant education but
certainly the people who are adopting
here are not the same people who are
adopting here nor the same people who
are the last ever to buy a car who are
adopting here so the people who study
innovation diffusion using this sort of
model break it down into social
categories but the constant in these
studies is that the thing is the thing
if it is a a type of hybrid corn it's a
type of hybrid corn if it's like an
automobile it's an automobile
if it is a you know an iPod it's an iPod
when you try to apply this kind of
thinking to intellectual diffusion or
intellectual innovation instead of
material innovation let us say when you
try to apply it to a religion or
political philosophy or a social outlook
or to institutions that are inspired by
those things then you get a new
complication that you don't have when
you apply it rather simply to an area of
technological diffusion and that is that
the way the thing is understood may
change in other words let's say you know
those people who became Christians
between one and two hundred AD did not
have the same view of Christianity as
those people who became Christians to
standard deviation deviations from the
mean later so that if you compare the
Christianity described by st. Paul in
the epistles of the New Testament and
you see him assuming that the Christians
belong to very small groups of people
who who meet in private homes many of
the leaders are women and a
characteristic of the meeting as that
people will witness miracles and that
they will sense the receipt of gifts of
the Holy Spirit that is to say they will
feel the Holy Spirit enter into them and
abling to do them to do things that they
could not otherwise do
such as heal the sick or handle serpents
without being bitten or speak in tongues
or understand other people when they
speak in tongues tongues meaning speech
that is otherwise unintelligible not in
any known language this is what you what
we would alcohol Pentecostalism and that
is how christianity is described at that
time but you go 200 years later or even
100 years later and the christianity is
very different so that by the time of by
the time you get around to 300 the the
end point and i'm talking about for this
comparison you're at a stage where you
have the possibility of an emperor will
sponsor a religion will declare it to be
the religion of the entire empire you
have an establishment of of bishops and
patriarchs who have spatial
responsibility for the appointment of of
priests you have mechanisms that have
begun to to show up for distinguishing
true faith from false faith and it's
very possible that most of those people
who became christians here would not
still have been christians if you've
gone up to here because christianity had
changed this of course is a zero-sum
situation in which as people become
christians it means that they're
stopping becoming something else so what
you have here is a change in which both
parts of a of a zero-sum division are
undergoing change according to the rate
and perception of of change the same
place so that
people who who let's say who are excited
by being the very first to adopt
something you know they're not going to
be excited once once it changes but
other people who would be horrified by
the idea of being the first to adopt
something or they may be attracted by
these changes similarly as communities
lose believers they begin to change
their attitude and to become let us say
more guarded and protective and
ultimately to become a rigidly and
agamous and to preserve their being say
that new will not allow anyone to join
our group which is sort of a flip side
saying we won't let anyone leave our
group and you get sort of frozen remnant
religions like these are Austrians of
today
all right I've talked about this in
other lectures so there's no there's
nothing new about this particular
approach to things but if you apply it
to the 19th century it has certain
implications in other words take Marxism
here you have a doctrine that begins in
the in the middle of the 19th century
leads to the Russian Revolution the
establishment the USSR and the creation
of Marxist communist parties not just
throughout Europe but throughout the
world if we had the numerical data we
could probably draw I'm sure in fact we
could draw a graph that would show the
number of adherence to Marxist thought
distributed over a time scale I am
persuaded largely by myself that if you
actually collected all that data
relating to who is a card
communists as a term eventually becomes
what of course or initially you didn't
have parties and cards and things like
that but my guess is that committed
Marxist if you aggregated them over time
you would have a curve that would look
like that that initially you had a few
people who became Marxist and then you
they talked about this doctrine to other
people and you had more people and they
talked about it and you have this this
logarithmic expansion of information now
no maybe no surprise of that maybe it
wouldn't be quite that curve but my
guess is that that would be a the likely
curve that you would get but the
implication that you have carrying over
from the example I gave with
Christianity is that Marxism changes and
that what Marxism is changes over time
according to the the nature of the
adopting population and what their what
their expectations are
when I have worked on religious
conversion for this point of view I've
used two axioms one of them is that
people do not voluntarily adopt a new
ideology or a new religion if by doing
so they think they are going to -
clearly damage their their economic or
social position secondly people do not
voluntarily adopt a new ideology but
rather when people adopt a new die new
ideology part of their expectation is
that it will satisfy needs or desires
that could not be satisfied by the old
ideology okay so when let us say workers
adopted Marxism and formed radical or
revolutionary labor unions or
revolutionary cells hoping to bring
about a communist revolution in this
country or that country were they you
know what was that bling to their to
their status if they were an
intellectual and and this is of course
one of the most difficult categories to
deal with when you come to the Marxism
is that it's a strongly intellectual
highly literate ISM so that many of the
people who are adopting are are
intellectuals do they reduce their
economic or social status by becoming
Marxist
yeah it it is hard to know and it's it's
it's been it's been debated with him you
know intellectual history as to what
what is the position of someone who
chooses to become a Riblet a
revolutionary Marxist whereas in fact
they are the inheritor or set to be the
inheritor of a land of the state or
something like that and usually one
turns to the idea of that the appeal is
not to the social of the economic status
but rather to the intellectual concept
of solidarity with the proletariat as
far as a proletariat goes the idea is
that by joining together in a radical
labor organization whether it's a
revolutionary cabal or whether it is a
militant labor union you you are
standing you are likely to improve your
status for both groups looking at it
from a slightly different angle the idea
that that you are through Marxist
ideology going to acquire some good that
you did not previously have I think
that's probably pretty valid I think of
the intellectuals or the the elites who
became Marxist felt that they were
gaining in in their intellectual or
philosophical or moral lives that they
were gaining something that was missing
in their in their life before if you
want to look at this sort of conundrum I
read back I recommend reading the play
dirty hands by jean-paul Sartre in it
you have a it's set in Eastern Europe
we're after world war two there has been
a takeover by a communist party the
party wants to assassinate a certain
nationalist leader because he's standing
in the way of a party but they don't
know how to do it because he is well
guarded and the intellectual who's a
member of the Communist Party volunteers
and says I will be the assassin and they
say well how will you do it he say well
I will become his secretary and I will
be able to gain close contact with them
because I'm like you I'm an intellectual
and I have the qualifications to be his
secretary and they say well how will you
you know when you carry out the
assassination are you willing to to
forfeit your life he said well my scheme
is that I will be his secretary I may be
butchering the plot a little bit but not
much
I'll be a secretary and I will be living
in the in his house with my wife and I
will claim that the assassination is a
crime of passion
because he has he was gone all Herman
Cain on my wife and and therefore is
deserving I will just cut this out of
youtube part of this anyway it was a
crime of passion so anyway this happens
and he assassinates the leader and he is
tried and he is not executed because the
court is willing to believe that he is
he was motivated by by a crime of
passion because of this man's advances
on his wife so he serves his term in
prison comes out and goes back to the
party and says I didn't the whole plan
was done I can I did the assassination I
did my time and now I'm back and the
party says yeah you know you're an
intellectual and not a worker and we
think it was a crime of passion
so we're not going to honor you
just because you carried out this
fascination because as intellectual you
couldn't really be part of this well now
that's not an unusual situation when you
have ideological movements the the
notion that people come from different
strata and are drawn to a movement
because they see it changing them are
offering an opportunity to change their
material motives may be dramatically
different when I studied this for the
rise of Islam I argued that the earliest
converts to Islam after the Arabs had
moved into Iraq in particular but the
earliest converts to Iran came from the
from the ends of the social spectrum
they were the poorest and the richest
they were the poorest because to be a
landless peasant and to be down-and-out
was a a worse position than to be a
flunky of the Arabs
you know shining their sandals or you
know whatever the flunkies did but in
order to be a flunky of the Arabs you
had to convert to their religion so for
landless peasants we know landless
peasants to some degree flocked to Islam
in Iraq and we know this because the
governor of Iraq tattooed the name of
their village on their hands and sent
them back to the village and said you're
just trying to evade labor and taxation
but we won't accept your conversion at
face value then at the other end of the
social scale you had Persian landowners
of great estate who had fought against
the Arabs been captured in battle and in
order to escape the slavery that would
be the normal status for prisoner of war
they converted to Islam
so the non-arab converts you now find
having a short bimodal distribution in
this earliest phase you have some of
them who are from the top of the social
scale this is like you know Tolstoy
becoming a socialist I mean some of the
richest people in Europe with strong
social positions endorsed these new
ideologies and then you had another
group where at the bottom of the social
scale who are joining the same movement
you find the same thing in Christianity
frequently people will say well
Christianity appealed to the slaves and
the Roman Empire well yeah it probably
did on the other hand when you read the
epistles of Paul he's not writing to
slaves he's not writing about slaves the
people he's writing to clearly are
people of substantial position in
society rather than people who are who
are toiling under the yoke of Roman
slavery so I think my guess is that when
you have movements of ideological change
that when they start out you have a
certain incoherence not necessary to the
doctrine itself but in coherence that
came from different expectations of
different groups who are joining the
movement and that changes in the
ideology have to do in part with
rationalizing these differences with
trying to get everybody on the same page
trying to make the the ideology or the
religion acceptable to people of who are
who come into it from different starting
points in that process
it's important that some people be
thrown out because they're not no
they're not club Abul they're not ready
to to move toward toward the center and
one of the things that you have with no
religions as you have with new 19th
century ideologies is that they
frequently split they have reciprocal
moments of of Anathem o where they
condemn one another like the Marxist
throwing out the anarchists for example
or later on the the Stalinist throwing
out the Trotskyites orb are broadly the
whole question of whether one is a
Marxist communist or a socialist because
this is another problem that you have is
that when you have multiple adoption
processes underway at the same time they
frequently conflict and they aim at at
the same audiences so so socialism in
various forms comes into being in the
19th century and it is not necessarily
compatible with Marxism although it may
adopt some of the views of Marxism and
ultimately you may get to a point you
did get to a point where Marxist
communist felt that their greatest enemy
was the Socialists and vice-versa
because they were essentially competing
for the same adopter population in the
same way that the Christians would find
the Manicheans to be a you know a
unacceptable religion
because really they're competing for the
same for the same adopter population so
in the life of st. Augustine he starts
out his first enthusiasm is as a
neo-platonists and he follows philosophy
then he shifts and becomes a mannequin
and as an ardent manikyam he really
thinks that mana ki ism is is the truth
then he becomes a Christian and at that
point the mana keys are the worst people
in the world they are magicians and
charlatans and frauds and any now
condemns the mana keys then he goes on
to discover that within Christianity
they're a bunch of heresies are really
awful and that he should now spend the
rest of his life as the Bishop of Hippo
in trying to destroy the the heretical
Christians that were in that were in
Tunisia at that time so uh you look at
this in the history of sectarianism and
you say okay you have this this sect and
that sect and they disagree on this and
here is their position on that you look
at them in terms of intellectual history
and you see conflicts and overlaps
but if you look at in terms of adopter
history you see competition for souls
where you might have two doctrines that
are extraordinarily similar but will
become hostile to one another because
they are competing for the same for the
same adopter population in other words
you're having a whole bunch of these of
these curves occurring at the same time
okay
so you have socialism Marxism utopianism
anarchism but then you have nationalisms
nationalisms I say the plural because
you have many different national
movements they're competing as well some
of the nationalisms are socialist some
of them are not some of them may be an
artistic eye in some respects another is
not but the defining characteristic of
the nationalisms is that they see
themselves as having a restricted
adopter pool now that adopter pool may
consist of all of the people who have a
certain quality whether they realize it
or not like you can say all those people
who speak German should be part of
German nationalism even though they are
spread across ten or so countries so you
have German speakers in Poland German
speakers in Russia
German speakers in Hungary German
speakers and in the Slovakia or Bohemia
German speakers in Germany and so forth
but you can have a German nationalism
that is far broader than than any nation
and then you can try and operationalize
it or you can have a nationalism that is
smaller than than an existing political
entity take Basque nationalism or a
Catalonian nationalism in Spain where
you have a Spanish kingdom a Spanish
kingdom of long history and that long
history has included a number of
different regions that have linguistic
differences in the case of Catalan
not that different from from Castilian
Spanish in the case of Basque an
entirely different language and so you
can have a nationalism that develops
defining the nation according to
according to ace to something that is
not parallel to the polity the adopter
pool then is is kind of a notional thing
I know that Benedict Anderson's work on
imagined communities sort of presumes
that that a community comes together and
imagines itself in terms of everyone
being a part of it and that becomes an
operational reality through the
operations of the press and the adoption
of national languages and so forth
but it doesn't always work that way in
other words if you look at the history
of Arab nationalism be very difficult to
apply this notion of an imagined
community but you could say everyone
whose mother tongue is Arabic is an Arab
and therefore part of the great Arab
nation and this is what an early Arab
nationalist or even Arab nationalists
found to the 1950s would say but then if
you looked at it from say Benedict
Anderson's notion that the underlying
factor should be a shared language and
say yeah but Arabs and Morocco can't
understand Arabs in Yemen and Arabs in
Yemen can't understand you know Arabs in
in in some other area or you have people
who are classified as Arabs who don't
speak Arabic like oh the Somalis who
sort of Djibouti ends up in the Arab
League for reason was totally unknown
ah plus you have the fact that the word
Arab was considered really up even into
the early 19th century as applying to
only two people who spoke Arabic who
lived east of Egypt Egypt had Egyptians
Arab Honor in Egyptian cloak will
dialect referred to nomads referred to
better one
it didn't referred to you know you know
and a mystery I'm an Egyptian now and
I'm honor but you know who's going to
say that Arabs are you know dirty
battles the same thing with Turks
thought we talked about Turkish tassel
with nationalism but in the 19th century
the word Turk was a pejorative term for
a nomad if you were a member if you were
a citizen the subject of the Ottoman
Sultan are you or not Turk you were Oh
small look you're an ottoman and so we
have this anomaly it's time when we have
something called ottomanism the late
19th century people say well can we have
a nationalism that is not predicated
upon a language or an ethnicity but
rather upon a constructed state defined
identity which we can call ottoman you
had people who were devoted to
ottomanism and others who came to voted
to Arab nationalism or to Turkish
nationalism and there adopt their their
conceptual not adopter pools are all
overlapping so some Turkish nationalists
will say well Turkish nationalism should
include all of the people who speak
related Turkish languages in Central
Asia
so Turkic nationalism of this sort would
include all the people of the Turkish
speakers of the Ottoman Empire plus
those people who lived in the Central
Asian possessions of the Tsar or later
of the USSR going all the way across to
Kazakhstan which borders in China and
now we would say well those are
different languages
Istanbul ooh Turkish augury Turkish
chicken Turkish is back Turkish Kyrgyz
Turkish Kazakh Turkish these are all
different languages they are but they
are actually closer to each other than
Moroccan Arabic is to Iraqi Arabic
Moroccan Arabic to me just sounds like a
jumble of constitutes I have no idea
what they say but it's it's a difficult
dialect of Arabic and it's very
different from say the dialect of
Tunisia
rather than I like to leave it so that
so even the definition of what
constitutes a language becomes a
complicating factor and you know other
places where you have a language that
everyone agrees upon that it's one
language and yet you have no nationalism
developing because you have other
divisions and here in particular in in
India in the 19th century you have the
line we've known as Punjabi there is a
province of Punjab in Pakistan and a
province of Punjab in India they speak
exactly the same language they are
divided by religion and there are three
religions you have Hinduism
predominantly among the Punjabis of
India Islam predominantly among the
Punjabis of Pakistan then you have the
six who show up in both India and
Pakistan and who have no state of their
own defined by by their religion is
there a national literature that could
have been used to generate a state
ideology yeah the same romances the same
poems the same
literary figures are esteemed on both
the Pakistan and the Indian side of the
border
but you don't get any movement of
Punjabi nationalism that sweeps across
the entire Punjabi speaking population
so simply having a a let's say a proto
national language let's say a language
that is physically unified a mutually
understandable that it could develop
into a national language and the basis
for a nationalism does not mean that
you're actually going to have it the
nationalism is not a necessary
development it is a contingent
development it depends upon other
circumstances now what those
circumstances were in the nineteenth
century or even in the twentieth century
are very obscure no why do you have a
Catalan nationalism in Spain but you
don't have a Venetian nationalism in in
Italy when the dialect of Venice would
be dramatically different from the
dialect of say Florence where you have
kind of the the B or I'm out the
homeland of of the unified Italian
language what what are the things that
determine where you have a nationalism
where you don't but I would say that
part of it has to do with this question
of of overlapping adopter pools that a
larger nationalism is going to
conceptually have a larger adopter pool
than a smaller nationalism on the other
hand with Arabic it turned out the
adoption pool was too large and you
never you give at Arab nationalism
developing in this comprehensive fashion
as a literary trend but never as a
significant political phenomenon
assuming that the
that the League of Arab states is not a
significant political entity which it
frankly never never has been so what I'm
what I'm trying to suggest here is that
in that period of the Roman Empire and
in the 18th and 19th centuries or say
1750 to 1950 that you have parallel
periods of extraordinary intellectual /
spiritual you know / philosophical
identity movements and that they are
competing with one another and that we
we have a hard time fathoming this
comparison because we tend to
distinguish religions from philosophies
or religions from political ideologies
but if you look at them as parallel
overlapping adoption processes with
competing concepts of what your adopter
pool is then you're perhaps closer to
understanding some of the some of the
complications that arise and some of the
modifications that you get in order to
to hold your adopters the one most
obvious being which I mentioned in
earlier lecture having to do with
Marxism and the failure of the
revolution to come you say well the
Marxist had thought the revolution come
in Germany the revolution that that
started in Germany aborted and the
effective revolution was in Russia and
then you had later revolutions in other
areas particularly in China
although that more a civil war than a
revolution but the fact that it didn't
come in Germany which have the where the
industrial proletariat were such a
powerful part of the population where
you have so many leading intellectuals
who were committed to the Marxist cause
what do you do when the revolution does
not come now my comparison would be with
William Miller back in the 1840s what do
you do when you've predicted the Last
Judgement and the end of the world and
it doesn't come you know what do you do
the next day you you change your date
you keep changing the date or you or you
say it actually came but you do
something to to save the theory so you
have Marxist of 1920s or 30s coming up
with new interpretations of Marxism that
that explain why the revolution did not
come and the reason for these changes is
in order to to to hold on to their
members no you don't want everyone you
know quitting the party simply because
the revolution didn't come you want them
to say in the party and so you change
your ideology
the Arab nationalists do you have to
write their late about without issue and
say that they were natural yes I you
know the example here is is the Arab
revolt in the Ottoman Empire where you
where you have to do something to
account for the circumstances that and
so you you get rid of some people or you
redefine them in certain ways so Marxism
becomes a non revolutionary doctrine or
it becomes a revolutionary doctrine in
which the revolution is still only
believed in by the Maoists and the
Trotskyites
and the mainstream are now interpreting
a different way and ultimately the
primary triumph of Marxism ISM is in
university professorial swear ultimately
we all became Marxist we did became
revolutionaries then become party
members on the other hand a very large
proportion of a university faculty will
will say in that particularly in the
history department will say that if you
want to understand society you must
start with the infrastructure let's say
how did people make a living how did
they produce the food how did they build
institutions that would that would
produce some sort of social solidarity
or class structure based upon this
infrastructural this in structural
infrastructural base you wouldn't have
to have a dialectic you wouldn't have to
have a formal class sequence but you
could simply say the material order is
more important than the spiritual order
in the early 19th century there's pretty
much consensus that the spiritual order
was more important than me
than the material order most people
right down through let's say the first
quarter of the 20th century
were oriented primarily toward their
religious group not toward their
political party or toward their their
nationalist leanings and yep these
things would overlap because these you
know you're having parallel you know
parallel movements is the spiritual
order more important than the material
order we are still debating that and so
virtually everyone in academia would say
Darwinian evolution is true and
intelligent design or divine creation is
an error
well the intelligent design the divine
creationism is something that people
will move toward if they feel that the
spiritual sense of things is the most
important they say well we really don't
care about those fossils or about that
their DNA whatever it is because we know
from our books of Revelation
what the truth is now that competition
between a spiritual realm and a material
realm intellectually in the Universities
of the material realm it has hold sway
more than the spiritual realm now is
that all attributable to Marxism no not
all but but there's a little a little
tinge of it I found it out one year when
uh well seven eight years ago an Iranian
student came to Columbia and I met him
he was not at my department he said oh
I'm so happy to be here at Columbia
because this is where I'll be able to
learn of a Berrien interpretation of
history for a professor Dabashi and a
Marxist interpretation of history from
you
I thought me
you know my conservative Midwest
background looked upon Marxism as
something like you know criminality of a
serious sort and the idea that someone
to think I was a Marxist seemed absurd
and yet as a social and economic and an
economic historian I certainly do affirm
that the material infrastructure is
where I start in my in my analysis of
things and I'm disinclined to ascribe
very much - pure - pure spiritual
motivation or okay so what I would say
is that Marxism evolves it evolves
according to an adopter curve in which
people like me to the griot Marxist will
be very very late adopters which we've
discarded all that early stuff we
discarded the revolution we discarded
the dialectic we discarded you know the
the poor labouring proletariat but we
sort of like the inversion of Hegel's
notion of the primacy of the spiritual
over the material and we go for the go
for the material these movements all
evolved so that nationalism is not a
constant nationalism is one thing when
you are hoping to join Garibaldi on the
battlements and you know fight for
Italian Italian freedom or Italian unity
as opposed to what comes along later
when you were conscripted into the
Italian Army and sent to Ethiopia or
Libya and told to to fight for the king
where your nationalism may now become
somewhat attenuated but nevertheless
you're part of the doctor pull you're
part of the National National Population
and these movements these foreign wars
will all be interpreted as
manifestations of of nationalism so that
the magazines that are published in
fascist Italy dealing with Libya all
see it as the new Rome now Italy has
regained this piece of the Roman Empire
so you have marvelous articles about the
Roman ruins in in Libya and and so on to
manifest this kind of nationalism now
these isms that I'm talking about I've
stressed the ones that are in Europe
although nationalism has a way of
spreading but then soda socialism so
does Marxism they become syncretic as
they spread so that they do not
necessarily retain the same
characteristics but they would have have
in their earliest manifestations but
then there are other things that happen
that seem to be autonomous and yet
they're happening at the same time and
here the one that that stands out for
its long-term consequences is the Meiji
Restoration in Japan the Japanese land
holders who have dominated the society
under the Tokugawa Shogunate for several
hundred years
they came to realization in the middle
of the 19th century that their military
capacity was insufficient to protect the
Japanese islands from contact with with
foreign influences there was a lot of
disagreement on what should be done
about that situation the Tokugawa
Shogunate had an ideology that was based
a fundamentally on warfare because you
had face of the elite of the population
was made up of samurai who were a
hereditary caste of warriors who were
brought up to be you know to be warriors
basically they were watched a lot of you
know Hong Kong movies and so forth learn
how to do it right but they didn't feel
that they were capable of being warriors
with respect to the to the foreign
warships that were spotted off the coast
of Japan in a complicated series of
arguments and debates among these these
land holders they persuaded the Tokugawa
family to step down from the Shogunate
and they decided that the land of the of
the Shogun and the land of many other
major land owners should be turned into
national land and be handed over to the
Emperor em so in 1867 the Emperor was
basically made the biggest landowner in
Japan
or you know by having his status as
Emperor restored that's why it's called
the meiji restoration meiji is the the
title the name of the period when a
japanese monarch assumes the office of
emperor there's a regnal name that he
adopts and so meiji becomes the regnal
name for for this period
this is 1867 you have a situation
strikingly similar to what happened 40
years earlier 60 years earlier in Egypt
under Mohammed Ali
that is to say suddenly the state
acquires a huge amount of wealth because
this land is being handed over not only
that but when the land was handed over
the land had been used to produce
revenues that would support the samurai
so now the emperor is given the job of
paying the salaries of the samurai
within ten years those salaries are
converted into government bonds and the
samurai basically go to work as you know
bureaucrats and doesn't spend and so
forth having spent hundreds of years as
professional warriors they they stopped
doing that what happens to military well
just as with Muhammad Ali in Egypt the
military adopts conscription so you go
from having an elite military caste of
highly trained soldiers to having
conscripts with military service of four
years plus additional years in reserve
are required of every Japanese or
reaches the age of 21 in a very short
number of years Japan becomes a major
military power
as did Egypt under Mohammed Ali to the
point that say between nineteen
elaborative 1930 Egypt became powerful
enough to threaten the the automat the
entire Ottoman Empire so in a period
from 1867 down to the end of the say
down to 1880 or so in those 13 years
during that period of time Japan becomes
powerful enough to go to war with China
and say the sino-japanese war that
basically results in Japan taking over
Korea or begins with Japan trying to
take over Korea and this time they they
get Korea and then turn Korea into a
source of raw materials iron ore in coal
for their for the industries when you
tell this story about Muhammad Ali in
Egypt or about mahmoud ii who does
similar things in the ottoman empire
starting in 1829 you tell the story
normally as the influence of europe and
the modernization of of the military you
know using european instructors and
schools and so forth and so on with
japan that's harder to do
japan is a very very long distance away
in the case of the ottoman empire you
can show that there was awareness of
europe on the part of the of the Emperor
maha the second you can show there was
an awareness of Europe on the part of
Muhammad Ali in Egypt but you can't
really show that there was much
awareness of Europe on the part of the
Meiji Emperor
you know the Meiji Emperor who serves
for a very long time as Emperor was
brought up in a completely traditional
completely traditional background
his mother was a concubine of the
preceding effort which meant that he
never saw her when he was born he was
placed by the palace bureaucracy with a
ocurred ear and his wife to be brought
up in their home and he never saw his
father I don't think the I think he's
about six years old before his father
actually you know looked at him and sort
of nodded and then he was taken away
again so he didn't grow up in the palace
he didn't grow up knowing anything about
his father he was nominally assigned a
mother who was the Empress there was
Memphis the Emperor had one wife and
every child the Emperor had that
concubine if that child survived long
enough and met the standards of the
court then that child was assigned a
mother who was the Empress so
technically he becomes the the child of
the Emperor and the Empress he has
nothing to do with that he's brought up
entirely by court functionaries who are
completely removed from the act of
political life of Japan because it's
compared to the Tokugawa Shogunate in
which the Emperor's have no power and
haven't had any power for hundreds of
years so what he learns he learns from
reading the Confucian classics and then
a certain degree about Buddhism when he
becomes Emperor functionally in 1867 he
does not change we know of nothing
written by the Meiji Emperor except that
every year at the beginning of the year
he would write a haiku on the year's
annual topic so everyone would write a
new year's haiku on a topic chosen by
the palace you know
the moon over mount Fujiyama all right
now the emperor writes his haiku and
everyone else of asked of artistic
aspiration of the country likes a haiku
on the same theme so we have the
collection of a haiku written by the
emperor this is only his only known
writings all the pronouncements put out
in his name were written by by court
functionaries and yet he took he took
this modernization very seriously so
that if there's gonna be a new army oh
that would be a powerful army he felt
that he should go on maneuvers with the
army so he could see the new army and
operation he could inspire them by his
presence and he did a great personal
discomfort he would have himself carried
in a sedan chair out to a out to a
military encampment or proving grounds
or practice area even it was 100 miles
away in order that he could observe his
new army in maneuvers because it was
going to inspire them but everything we
know about the meiji emperor reflects
the fact that he is trained as and
continues in his deepest soul to be a
Confucian gentleman with no inspiration
from the West at a personal level
whatsoever he will do his duty as to to
to the to the land and to his people but
he's not a nationalist in the way that
say a Bismarck or a or a Matt Seanie or
Mohammed or Mahmoud the second would be
a nationalist he's he doesn't follow any
ism in particular so you end up with one
of the most powerful countries in the
world coming into being almost from a
zero state in the second half of the
19th century without emanating from this
from this
complex welter of isms and changes in
the economic and social order that were
affecting Europe and the colonized areas
in that in that time period and it makes
you wonder well did you really have to
go through all of that tumult
in Europe sometimes I I think of this I
think well those first centuries of the
Roman Empire from say 200 to 300 where
you had such complexity well would it
have been better to be in the Persian
Empire where you didn't have it oriented
to a lesser degree I mean is there a
necessary connection between a moment of
of enormous complexity and change and
the wealth and power that come to be
associated with in other words we
attribute the talking about the new
power balance of this chapter we
attribute the rise of European power to
physical changes and to ideological
changes that are treated as though they
are singular and have no comparison in
history to some degree I think the
technological changes are singular
particularly those that relate to the
movement of people goods and information
in terms of the ideological changes it's
not clear to me that this is that
singular an era it only appears to be
because we make a kind of artificial
distinction between religious adoption
or fill religious or philosophical
adoption processes and ideological
adoption processes that become a
distinct of the 19th century all right
that I got through this lecture rather
incoherently but
for better or worse that's where we are